mom-mom never changes when she consumed
the basement those who survived did so
by collecting items and trinkets when
they realized how to fight back they set
out across the ruins of the vast
underground labyrinths to build new
synergies established new strats and to
form win streaks as afterbirth was
released what had been the basement
United beneath the flag of the 109
republic dedicated to old-school values
of nerfing items adding guaranteed
damage rooms as the republic grew so did
its needs the players spread to the
subreddit seeking support and buffs in
the dry merciless expanse of request
threats they returned with tales of a
dlc untouched by the nerfs that scorched
the rest of the basement and a brand-new
collection of items and unlockables
headman mobilized his army and sent it
to release the rest of the content then
restore the donation machine to working
condition but across the basement
another society had risen under a
different flag a vast army of players
forged in the conquest of the Arg tin
foils Legion almost a month has passed
since the Republic held the basement
just barely against the legions
onslaught the Legion did not retreat
across the subreddit that gathered
outlandish theories but holes were hurt
keyboards clattered through it all the
house on the hill is stayed open for
business under the control of its
mysterious overseer mr. McMillan and his
army of Nicholas employees you are isaac
implored by mom to just give up and let
her win what seemed like a simple escape
attempt
has taken a turn for the worse